this will be
further way further into the frontier
like I've made leaps in this book that
goal I would say far beyond
what I managed in maps of meaning
you're writing a book we who wrestle
with God and I guess this ties back to
my earlier question and the note you
wrote in maps of meaning to your father
saying you you you're struggling to
articulate these ideas and in the 23
years that have have gone since matzo
meaning do you feel like you're closer
to articulating those ideas and is this
well I'm practicing that all the time
you know each of the lectures is an
opportunity to push that
capacity to articulate a little further
to make it a little more differentiated
to make it a little more accessible to
make it make it clearer and so and it's
an unfolding right because the ideas
well first of all they're not my ideas
but the ideas were implicit and then
they unfold right maybe they unfold
first of all in Revelation and then they
unfold in art and then they unfold in
narrative and then they unfold in
philosophy and then they unfold in
apprehensible public speech it's
something like that and it's a constant
unfolding and so you know I'm for me I'm
on the edge of my ability to do that
unfolding and that's the edge that I
occupy and I think the reason that my
lectures are successful by lectures
they're not really lectures they're
conversations with the crowd in some
real sense but the reason they're
successful is because it
they offer people an opportunity to
participate in the process of that
unfolding because it's not it's not only
unfolding for me in some sense it's
unfolding for those two with whom I'm
communicating
at the same time and the lectures
the public events are a place for that
to happen you know you know it's the
same thing in some real sense that
you're doing when you're playing your
music you know you're
you're having
you know an idea is unfolding you have
you feel the energy and you see what
resonates and right you see what
resonates it's a conversation right
right right right and you know when a
concert goes great the audience is the
same place you are and everyone is doing
the same thing it's a form of collective
worship fundamentally in celebration and
celebration of what well it's the
unfolding of an artistic Vision
obviously because that's what you're
doing on stage and
um and and and there's an
improvisational element to that which is
why people like live concerts uh and a
participatory element and I would say
the same thing applies
to my public engagements and and it's
it's extremely it's demanding but it's
extremely
um engaging you know very so we who
wrestle with God then will that be a
distillation of your public speaking in
in a book
it'll and and with the advantage to a
book is that you can really it's really
rigorous
and so it's it's a distillation that
that's that's that's that's a good way
of thinking about it it's a further
development of the ideas that I
developed in maps of meaning and then
unfolded in my last two books and this
is this will be
further way further into the frontier
like I've made leaps in this book that
goal I would say far beyond
what I managed in maps of meaning and
there's much more original thought in
this book than there is in 12 rules or
Beyond order because those books were
really
popularizations in some sense
of the concepts that I developed in maps
of meaning and I was able to make them
more apprehensible because I spent 20
years lecturing about Maps meaning and
so I learned how to communicate the
ideas in a manner that was
grippable and but with this new book we
wrestle with God
I I I have a cardinal idea
um
that
it's a revolutionary idea
now it's not my idea in the same sense
we've already been talking about it's
the unfolding of something that's being
implicit and but but I think I've
unfolded it a nice another another layer
that's very exciting so I I can give you
like an overview in some sense well
you act out a story and not only do you
act out his story
but you perceive the world through a
story
and so then the question is well what
story
should you act out
and so then you might think
of that is what story should you emulate
or you might think about it as what
story should you imitate now there's
hints of that in darkness like the
imitation of Christ let's say but
anyways what should you imitate well you
should imitate
that which is the highest well is that a
description of the objective world it's
like no because you can't imitate the
objective world
not obviously
it's complicated but not obviously you
imitate something like a spirit
right you which is a pattern of behavior
that's a that's a way of thinking about
a spirit it's a pattern of behavior so
you might say well if you're in a
concert that whole audience is animated
by a spirit it's the spirit of music
whatever that spirit is and it inhabits
everybody simultaneously and it's
obviously a pattern because everyone's
moving the same way it's a pattern right
and there's Saint physiologically like
the band is synced together
physiologically you know and there's
something moving about that literally
because it moves you well
there's a pattern that you should
emulate
it's a pattern of character and the
stories about God in the biblical Corpus
are
representations of the pattern to
emulate they're not a description of the
structure of the objective world they're
not proto-scientific theories they're an
embodied ethos and it's very complex
ethos because you might say well who
should you be well you can't sum it up
in a sentence because life is too
complicated to sum up in a sentence
um you could say love your neighbor as
thyself if you had to sum it up in a
sentence but still that has to be
unpacked God is presented in the
biblical Corpus as a character
and as a character that calls to
to emulate I'll give you a couple of
examples so for example
in the story of Noah God is presented as
the spirit that calls to the wise in
times of trouble to prepare
you might say well do you believe in God
he's like well do you let that spirit
guide you well you do if you're wise and
awake
do you believe well it depends on what
you mean by belief if you follow the
spirit that calls you when you're wise
to prepare in times of Crisis then you
believe
in the most fundamental sense because
you acted out and you see the world well
and then God is represented
as a character with multiple dimensions
and each story is a representation of a
dimension so another example in the
Abraham story which is a very
fundamental story
uh God is represented as the spirit that
calls the
overly dependent and secure to the
adventure of their lives
say Do you believe in that it's like
well do you leave your place of security
and have the adventure of your life yes
or no no then you don't believe yes then
you follow that Spirit that's the belief
is the following it's not a
propositional statement it's the
following then in the story of Exodus
God is the spirit that calls those who
labor under tyranny to
shoulder the burden and responsibility
of their autonomy it's like do you
believe in that
well figure that out for yourself it's
like
do you think slavery is wrong well of
course it's wrong it's obvious that it's
wrong it's like yeah well there's a
reason it's obvious and it isn't because
you figured it out
it's and it's and it wasn't obvious to
many people throughout the vast spans of
history in fact quite the opposite was
obvious it's like if I can make you do
what I want why don't I have the right
to do that or why isn't that even the
definition of right
it's like that's a really hard question
and modern people and I would say that's
particularly true of people on the left
they just record it it's obvious that
slavery is wrong really it's that
obvious is it why did it take us until
like 500 years ago to figure that out
then that's so obvious
and and so well so part of this book is
an investigation into the character
of God so to speak and viewed not
entirely through the lens of the
biblical Corpus but to a large degree
and so
and it's an investigation the title we
who wrestle with God that's what Israel
means the word Israel means we who
wrestle with God which is really
something because Israel
the people of Israel are God's chosen
people and what that implies at a
narrative level is that if you wrestle
with God you're one of the chosen people
and everyone wrestles with God
whether they know it or not
and so
and that's true even more for atheists
than for most religious people because
they spend almost all their time
wrestling with God
they wouldn't Proclaim themselves as
atheists otherwise they'd be off you
know chasing girls or something which
probably is what they should be doing
but the end of demons and dostoesky
talks about but it's better to be off
the fence not believing yeah God than on
the fence you know as an agnostic yeah
yeah and all that and you see that in
the Book of Revelation too because
Christ says very straightforwardly in a
division of Christ uh is accompanied by
the sentiment the that
those who sit on the fence are those who
will be subject to the harshest judgment
[Music]
thank you
[Music]